breaking cover before dawn the first
sighting of boris johnson in days but no
running away from the allegations and
anger over downing street parties
the day got brighter but the mood around
here is dark a pm who wishes he could
turn back the clock
but mps returning from their
constituencies after the weekend worry
the damage is irreversible i think
people may well be too angry to forgive
but it remains to be seen and how much
anger in your constituency how powerful
absolutely furious
well gotta keep going
and this is what that looks like cabinet
ministers trying to get back to the
business of governing with permission mr
speaker i would like to make a statement
from statements on the bbc license fee
funding frozen for two years
to migrant crossings in the channel
trying to change the agenda but having
little luck home secretary pretty patel
under fire for telling me she fully
supported the pm despite demanding the
police to prosecute the public during
those lockdowns how on earth can she
defend the prime minister who has
publicly admitted breaking the rules she
isn't even waiting for the sue gray
report beth rigby asked her are you
reserving judgment until the surah grey
report comes out she said no on the
contrary i have publicly supported the
prime minister tens of thousands of
fines were given out in the months when
downing street was holding parties
and tonight fresh accusations about the
downing street garden party on may the
20th 2020 which the pm attended mr
johnson's former top advisor turned foe
dominic cummings says he warned the pm
against holding the event after another
aide martin reynolds invited over a
hundred staff to drinks when the country
was in lockdown
dominic cummings wrote in his blog i
said to the pm something like martin's
invited the building to a drinks party
this is what i'm talking about you've
got to grip this madhouse the pm waved
it aside
not only me but other eyewitnesses who
discussed this at the time would swear
under oath this is what happened
what's your reaction to tonight's
allegations well clearly someone's not
telling the truth and if that turns out
to be boris johnson then that is
terminal misleading parliament
misleading the public as prime minister
uh that's a cardinal sin and that will
be career ending for him mr cummings
account was repeated to me today by
second down the street source who told
me that the prime minister did know
about the may 20th event in advance and
let it go ahead anyway that flies in the
face of what downing street has said all
along that this is simply untrue
more questions than for sue grey's ever
expanding
investigation and a development that
will further infuriate already furious
mps
how many emails have you got on this in
the past few days is it really getting
cut through yes it certainly is i've had
hundreds of emails on this topic yeah
more than one more than the dominant
commons incident
i would say it's on a par with with
dominic comings well that's very
worrying for the prime minister isn't it
yes it's just and it should be worrying
for the prime minister and indeed at
number 10 i think they need to know the
level of anger that is being that is
felt out there in the country and that
something needs to change just to be
clear especially worrying for
conservative mps in marginal red wall
seats the prime minister he has a lot of
convincing to do because i
again and my constituents are all
convinced at the moment my ass to the
prime minister is to really dig in and
is to really you know speak from the
heart speak from the put the sue grey
apart aside if you can't turn things
around if the constituents and
you know the british people don't want
to give you a chance then you have to at
that point reconsider
so many in his party and the public now
having second thoughts about the man
behind this door and even if he survives
the scandal can he ever really recover